take names and take care perfect hi
there reject nation I'm Greg Alba I'm
Jean Humphrey and I'm Katrina Alicia so
this video came out a while ago and
we're finally watching it
today I can't tell you how many times I
got blown up with questions about why we
haven't covered it we just did it but
now we're doing it right now because
Katrina's here oh boy I made a video to
get views if we have a guest you know
how it goes getting us in gear I
shouldn't reveal the behind the curtains
to do your show Avengers end game every
mission comes from top reward to your
patron Lance door who's in Canada right
now as of filming this he is actually
traveling all Europe with his family
cheating on his girlfriend Wow
well she's with I mean yeah well he's
messaging me and that was a mistake on
your end Lance Wow if you want me to cut
this out of the video you got a double
your pledge blackmailing you know
I screwed we're in the best
[Music]
ah
[Music]
shmow I love it that would reduce the
future
[Music]
oh no I should want to go look you you
are way more attractive I never get to
do anything important
let me job no I grow weary of listening
to your argument actually I grow weary
of pretty much everything about this
whole place I hear so many years
yes Wow oh my gosh thank you so much I
love you I know character-wise that
makes some sense you know I think it
worked
whoa
[Music]
no mighty Thanos census indicates really
what the fourth you guys what kind of
missiles are we using here shoot them
again and do it right this time
yes my wallet
[Applause]
oh yes up in the animations and love it
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it was
thank you
there's just one more thing with that so
unless your plate or size brainwashed
buddy or spine I could do this all day
there we go all right
can't somebody do something is there a
doctor in the house if only there was a
device that could reverse things that
were damaged okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
we can fix that too we can we can I have
some questions about him sitting back
and letting history play out so many
questions no let's make him yoga
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
as amazing that was every bit worked
like amazingly Batman stepping in with
us now what I love about what the hizzy
group does is they make like these
hilarious bits mm-hmm but every once in
a while and I feel like actually a lot
of these I'm sure the comments are
loaded with people being like sure that
you would work but there's a pretty good
amount of these I'm like that won't work
mine Thor's hammer especially they found
a way just drop it on top of it yeah
that makes perfect sense actually yeah
that was one of my favorite ones from
from this comfy okay not at all come on
I mean you can nitpick endgame because
they're so in the moment you don't think
about well why don't you just do this so
that's why I love their writers because
yeah they think about these little
things that don't come into mind in the
moment but they're like actually listen
up with what we've seen in the MCU yeah
you could just drop the hammer on
we would never which is captured in the
ship and then she could have just time
travel I don't know why that didn't work
did they have to be at a specific point
in the movie she had to stay there just
stop Thanos from it was to stop animals
from finding the stone but they were
trying to find at the same time this is
like Dan of snow stano's knows and they
could have like changed the timeline or
something so I guess she had to stay but
the same time she was able to time
travel out of that conundrum and they
wouldn't have time traveled back to
their time today knows his team and got
that of course suspension of disbelief
but everyone would have been dead in
that head would have been dead well you
see him slightly morph into tiny guy
like it's a very brief moment but when
the rock comes out he morphs into
ant-man but what this points out is why
didn't they just truck had that much
firepower to begin with we really had it
later on rider Rockets who were Rockets
guys I didn't plan funny if the red
skull thing like now would work in the
movie in any capacity but I loved it but
the idea of red skulls is being there
you Goit imagine he probably is just
bored out of his mind what do you do
that whole time just float around like
that's it I mean that board is [ __ ] it's
like do you know it's like you don't
touch yourself for so long his skin
didn't always look like that all this is
so wrong this is face it's redder oh I
don't know check now now Miz red yeah if
you find any detailed photographs or yes
by all means
well the wrong moment to at the end
juice whoa
that's something his he has covered
before with like Doctor Strange me will
do that because that's established in
infinity Warwick when he long does it
yeah it takes off the person's arm I
don't know why they never bothered to
bring that into play and also that whole
bit at the end with the time-travel
stuff I've got to give them a lot of
credit for that because a lot of people
have come out really confused about the
way the timeline works and yeah and the
way time travel works and for me I
surprisingly wasn't confused I
understood the way their rules worked
with time travel but with their rules of
how time travel works like not all them
not all of them like wait that doesn't
work but some of them could have really
worked
it hurts my brain cuz half the time I
get the concept of everything that you
yourself have done no matter where
you've traveled in time is your past
experiences like I get that aspect but
like yeah if they swipe up Black Widow
before she goes to get the stone then
wouldn't they create an alternate
timeline where they is just creating
like another yeah where they lost so and
that's what's really established when
the Hulk is talking with the ancient one
is that it creates multiple timelines
yeah the idea with cap at the end is
he's in an alternate timeline but at the
same time I can get confused with you
really like dive deep I try to keep my
mind simple about it but then when I
like dive deep I'm like okay now my head
starting record itself yeah would that
just create another one of the outcomes
where we live right yeah either way this
whole video was hilarious Willy Willy
Willy round Willy rel really
well-constructed really well thought out
I loved it
listen guys how it should have ended can
use some followers and I know there's
always another happy recover in their
video because we're like oh thank god we
could use a boost from these guys so go
subscribe to their channel check out
Katrina alyosha on Instagram and Twitter
subscribe the reject nation please click
notification bielski notice I went over
a video I'm and Lance
look if your girlfriend's watching he's
not cheating on you
but truth comes out if your child is
watching you're adopted I'm just letting
you know that you are not the biological
child of Lance door I'm really sorry
break the news to you buddy that's
what's going on right now we have a
beautiful name which I can't remember
you are blessed to have the foster
parents you have I'm Lance if you want
me to cut this out the video triple your
pledge and we're good to go buddy oh
yeah very rousing uh-huh
good just good stop and remember that
that you're special no matter who your
parents know your biology doesn't count
as much and more adoptions ought to
happen in the world yeah if you want
some type of little Damian running
around 66 is what I'm saying we have six
hundred sixty six thousand subscribers
now that was like all the comments on
yesterday's nine hundred sixty six
thousand six hundred sixty-six subscribe
I know we gotta get there after that
we're freezing the channel
no more allowed end it there